-I'm inclined to have you argue
your motion,
and then I'll consider
late-arriving petitions.
-I'm sorry for wasting
the court's time, your honor,
but it's impossible for me to
continue with this hearing.
-And why is that, Ms. Wexler?
-Because I'm no longer
an attorney.
-I'm sorry. What?
-I gave notice to the bar
two hours ago.
-Hey, welcome back, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're here with Rhea Seehorn.
That was a clip
from "Better Call Saul."
You directed a wonderful episode
this year.
So you're directing
your roommates --
not just your co-stars,
but your roommates.
-I did.
-How was that when you came home
after a long day's work
with your cast?
-Well, I mean we already talk
about the scenes,
as I said, ad nauseam, anyway.
So I kind of had it cleared
with them to discuss the scenes
we did.
That was episode 604.
So Patrick had the great therapy
scene as Hamlin
and it was when Jimmy's dressed
as Hamlin,
driving his car with Wendy
and all of that,
and so we discussed them
at length,
but by the time we got to set,
yeah,
they kind of laughed in my face.
-How did you --
-[ Laughs ]
-And you also had to direct
yourself
a great deal on that episode.
-Yeah.
-That was a big Kim episode.
Did you find that difficult or
was it nice to sort of take
your mind out of both places
in order to do the whole job?
-It is challenging, and I did
some press where people were
like, "Wow, you really wanted to
direct yourself a lot,
'cause there's huge Kim scenes
in that."
But that's not what it was.
It was just this jigsaw puzzle
of the calendar
of which directors can leave
the writer's room.
We have a lot of
writer-directors
and producer-directors, and so
I just got the episode I got.
But they put -- you know,
they put a huge infrastructure
in place, like there's no time
to watch playback,
plus that would --
-Yeah.
-I know there's some actors
that watch themselves
and then go back to set.
I could never.
-Yeah.
-It's just like you're just
constantly reminded of like,
"Oh, that's your face."
-Oh, 100%.
-That's what it still looks
like.
-Oh, yeah.
I would walk out and be like,
"My only note is I think we need
to stop doing this forever."
-100%, yeah.
Like, I can feel good about the
choices I'm making as an actor,
but for anybody old enough to
remember answering machines,
that very first time you made
the voicemail and you hear
your voice
and you're so alarmed.
It's like, "Seriously? That is
what everyone's listening to?"
-Yeah, you're like, "It sounded
like this the whole time?"
-Yeah, no one told me?
-And nobody told me?
[ Laughter ]
-Nobody has said,
"Seth, seriously,
don't ever speak again."
That's what it's like.
-It's only because you would
leave a voicemail
and you assumed that your
friends would call and be like,
"Hey, has something happened
to you?
You sound super [bleep] up
on that voicemail."
[ Laughter ]
But they're all just like,
"Hey, it's me.
Just calling."
Like nobody's taken aback, yeah.
-Because they're like, "Seth has
sounded like crap forever."
-Forever.
-That's always the way
he sounded like.
-Are you relieved that
you're almost now where,
you know, I guess four episodes
away from you not having
to worry about giving anything
away?
Because the longer people have
watched this show,
the more I feel they've been
desperate
to see how everything ends.
-Yeah.
-And you know.
And has it been exhausting
trying to keep those secrets
or has it been fun?
-It's been fun, because even
when people do say,
"So what happens to Kim?"
Or whatever,
they don't actually want you
to answer.
They would stop me
even if I started to speak.
-Yeah.
-But I am looking forward to
having a much bigger book club.
It's like I read this book by
myself and I don't get to talk
to anybody about what'd
you think of the ending?
So as we roll out these episodes
and the remaining episodes,
of course, I can't spoil whether
you'll see me again or not,
but they're bananas.
Nobody actually tracked exactly
how thoughtfully and intricately
this comes together and the
different storylines
that play out,
so I'm looking forward
to talking to people about it.
-It was such a cool show
because, you know, when I heard
they were doing a prequel to
"Breaking Bad", you know,
I was like,
"That seems strange,"
and it has been -- I didn't --
I will just say I thought
it was a bad idea.
-Yeah, sure.
-And I can say that now because
my instincts are often wrong
and I was totally wrong here.
And it was so great to again see
cast members
from "Breaking Bad"
that we love.
I mean, what you did, what
Patrick did, what Michael Mando
did -- like it was so wonderful
to see.
I'm really deeply sad it's
almost over, but I can't wait to
see it, and I'm so happy
for you.
-Thanks.
-Thank you for being back again.
You guys, one more time,
Rhea Seehorn.
A new episode of the last season
of "Better Call Saul" airs
this Monday at 9:00 P.M. on AMC.
We'll be right back
with Jeremy Allen White.